it's a beautiful day to be alive don't
let nobody [__] kid you tell you
otherwise
if you're above six you started the day
on the right foot you know I'm saying
but I have to tell you that
because you know that already you
[__] savages
you [__] savages
what's happened you bad [__]
uncle Joey here representing represent
life slinging dick and heightened balls
you understand me if that's not what
you're into
get the [__] off this feed right now cuz
we're going deep into the murky waters
it's Friday you made it another [__]
week down the drain and look at you
you're tip-top Magoo all week you didn't
know what am I gonna do with my life who
gives a [__] put on a pair of pants
squeeze your ball salute the flag and
let them know you're [__] coming in
you understand me why walk down there I
run down there where you can [__] one of
them when you could walk down there and
[__] them all that's the philosophy here
but Joey what's with the [__] ear
beatin I thought we were throwing down
we are throwing down I got a variety of
different debts today I got this one
here from my man Josh always on top of
his [__] game you know me I got a
switch the reef is around I went over to
[__] my people yesterday over that
sunset herbal they don't give a [__]
they got stars a debt they got to she's
they got [__] everything you
understand me if you go in there between
6 a.m. and 2:00 asks for my girl sky and
tell uncle Joey sanshin she'll throw you
an extra [__] number something right
you got the King Louie you got the
[__] [__] madman now look at this
one this is [__] Sleepless in Seattle
or some [__] I don't know what you do
we're gonna hit this [__] king Louis
first cuz that's how we roll you
understand me you gotta hit him when he
hit him all right [__] sometimes the
risk donor that I'm getting old people
I'm a week away from being 55 and I
don't give a [__]
I feel 25 you following me it's all in
your [__] mind anyway what's in your
heart what's in your nutsack everything
else is just a number you find I got the
[__] heart of a [__] tiger right
now at 55 you know why
cuz I got you [__] savages in my
corner I'm with you you with me and
they're with us or they wanna be with us
[__] them it's us against the world
ma'am I told you all we need is three of
us and we could take over a [__]
empire
anyway smooth you follow me
nice I can hear Chinese people yelling
as we [__] speak that means the reef
is going deep deep deep into the murky
waters don't forget if you want to get
your lung power improved you got to get
a bas Rutten h2o or breathing you start
with number one you do that 30 [__]
times three times a day you'll be
blowing [__] windows out when you do
a bong hit you understand me and then I
go for a walk when I'm up to 14 already
pretty singing I [__] gag me anyway
who gives a [__] I'm just giving you
little tips you use that with doctor
polices and you have to get one of those
half a [__] pennies and impress people
look at me blowing strawberry clouds
uh-huh
aren't you a [__] wizard uncle Joey's
over here blowing clouds and the [__]
that manages the devil the devil's
blattis aka
the gift from God to the devil to calm
him down here take this [__] devil
calm down all right
smoke some of this spread it around
just like that
we don't [__] around him give him
[__] pee test I was smoking like a
man with three arms I had no future but
I was smoking like a man with three arms
anyway we're gonna do a medley here
Rufus you know I'm saying we you here
for a couple minutes with uncle Joey why
cuz I love you because I'm telling you
what the [__] ax is up you lived all
week
you got your bub six [__] feet I don't
give a [__] if you eating out of a
garbage can right now you're alive
[__] that means you're alive and
guess what you can't get no down on them
so you're gonna go up like a [__]
stock market anyway I know it's going
down you little stock people huh
what are we gonna do Sal go [__]
yourself take your money bury the
[__] yard and mind your business
anyway so we did the King Louie let's
try this [__] monster
oh [__] look at this this is [__]
from Indies he musta feed a little
Italian for you Polly who [__]
italiano [__] Polly I don't see
your pal Italian Angelina man general
Abbas Davina anyway you know me I'm
international without a passport
who gives a [__] past watch pussy's here
I'm saying go look at Kansas and get
back to me then go to [__] in Europe and
try to offense and press your [__]
friends at the local coffee shop we went
to Bangladesh the people suck my dick
go to [__] Iowa they got people there
too were there bad [__] you
gotta talk to these poor [__] Gentiles
they confused from time to time
pilot to Bombardier if I had goggles I'd
put him on there in my swim bag anyway
you people bad [__] we made it
to another we got another podcast for
you my girl Bethany Ashton Wolfe do me a
favor go see her movie guys she said
listen she's one of us
she had a dream she stuck with it I know
the broad 20 [__] years she's banging
it out short films kitchen films now
she's got a [__] movie that's out
nationally it was like number [__]
four it was 3.5 million dollars to make
she got it up to 14 million I mean
listen do me the favor go watch her over
my girls Valentine's weekend you want
your wife to suck your dick yeah it'll
take her to see one of those movies from
time to time you people want to take
your wife to go see the mechanic then
you want to ask her for a [__] what
are you [__] crazy she just saw 18
people getting [__] murdered and you
wanted to lick your balls or type the
[__] individual or you don't get me
started it's Friday I get emotional
anyway I haven't shown them is so dumb
that's not like a doorman old man I got
the birthday show on the 17th at the
[__] ice house that's gone the 18th
at the Comedy Store is gone I'll tell
you what I got available you ready
[__] Sweet Home Alabama
Huntsville Alabama
I'm coming the first week of March like
a [__] I'm coming in like herpes you
understand me I'm coming in deep into
[__] Huntsville don't worry about
nothing I'm coming in via [__] New
York City with the goods you follow me
I'm gonna go hang out with white powder
ma for a couple of days she's got that
[__] from China she over she went around
the border she told the [__] nicest
people to suck a [__] she's bringing it
in direct so Huntsville Alabama
levity live I don't know what to
stand-up live in Huntsville I'm [__]
ready for you [__] I'm [__]
ready I want the Confederate flag I want
to see Leonard music when it's getting
music
I want to see dirty white people with no
shoes on I'm [__] ready you follow me
and the Confederate flag I got nothing
there's nobody all right
right away you gotta be raised this they
gotta be something listen go watch oh
let it Skynyrd live from Oakland 1977
they got a confederate flag up on stage
with the four [__] presidents all I'm
trying to do is pay respect I got
nothing against nobody
I love black beep I love Puerto Ricans I
love Hindus you know what I'm talking
about anyway Joey what's with the [__]
ear bleeding we're gonna smoke some
[__] dope or what it's Friday
I gotta get you in good shape two down
and two to go so we smoked the [__]
King Louie we smoked somebody's [__]
death on two legs Middle East cush
Middle East cush
in other words Isis grew this you know
what they're bad people but they grow
good weed what do you want from me
tonight
oh [__] and you got mad man og like I
need this [__] you sprinkle a little
here in your bowl I already had a nice
[__] that kind of come at my drags
wait watch is there free I have one
piece of wheat toast two slices of bacon
and a big-ass [__] fruit cup I'm
trying people I'm saying I'm trying to
get away from 300 the opposite direction
I'm gonna look good lady ladies I ain't
[__] around no more too bad I'm
married and too bad I come in a minute
I'm not to go so talk to one of those
[__] sexual encounter people here I'm
sayin you give money and every week they
take you today
it works on soldiers when they got PTSD
and [__] they come back
that dick doll stand up I am no prophet
my dick I just bra guy come quickly get
scared to come get an attack from behind
I'm saying anyway why am I telling you
this [__] it's Friday afternoon I invite
you to smoke weed right away Joey you
got tell me about your personal problems
is [__] anyway I don't give a [__] I'm
gonna go do an hour
exercise I gotta go do some right I
gotta go something I gotta find somebody
[__] fix the head do it's all [__]
up and that's it we made it another week
and guess what we're gonna make it next
week too why cuz you're bad
[__] you're gonna grab your
balls you're gonna write your goals
you're gonna look in the mirror and you
go who the [__] is gonna stop me you
know me same who the [__] gonna stop
your nobody your person I stop [__]
yourself I don't give a [__] if you
smoke weed eat a pot cookie as long as
you wake up the next morning ready to
stab a [__] the lung you got
you do want what day guys I'm saying and
you gotta [__] get it ain't nobody
gonna give it to you only pick the
Bluebird of happiness knocks on your
[__] door and says here's the dream
come true now [__] you [__]
you gotta go on and take it so stop
sitting there like I moved the law and
go out there make something [__]
happen nothing happens on the couch you
find three quarters is that what you
want three quarters I'm looking for the
[__] small envelope
I'm looking for the small I'm below and
just to try to keep alive everyday so
I'm gonna be a father to this little
[__] Savage I'm putting again the
goal is to strengthen your diaphragm see
I'm a fat [__] so the fat got all soft
and the diaphragm is all [__] soft
but ever since I've been doing bas
Rutten hates to all I'm ready to [__]
go I don't give a [__] you do this with
a little doctor beliefs breathing I
don't get scared numb long and I'm in
the bottom of jujitsu I don't get scared
no more when I can't breathe in a
[__] plane cuz I get anxiety all that
shit's gone anyway who cares the [__]
you got anxiety that everybody's got
[__] hang tight who remember today
remember the most important thing at the
end of day war all immigrants
pro-immigrant mentality is what is what
is what you mix it with American
ingenuity and next thing you know you're
[__] inventing a [__] company
called hustling you got 16 women sucking
your dick and you're in a wheelchair
who's better than you all right
that's [__] American ingenuity get up
grab your [__] heart salute the flag
and go out there and [__] let them
know you ain't [__] around it's
Friday but you still got a Monday
mentality and as usual they didn't give
my mother a finger but get the wrong
color corners I booked petróleo you're
setting can only go your coply tongue
they both a liar anyway I gotta let my
little spit come off from time to time
if not you know I go [__] bananas
Bochum ECOA
no Mira pingas ah you're so evil our son
TC might go by applause epitope mundo
aiyah
you know meringue ago and went oh gee no
get they met on [__] are you
anyway I love you [__] with all
my heart the pot gas comes back did
Bethany listen to don't forget about
what I told you feather my girl do me
this solid
take your girlfriend take it down here
you play with a little monkey in the
movie theater
aka rv-style you know I'm saying and
that's it nobody gets their feelings
hurt and you have a great weekend I love
your mother [__] with all my heart
don't forget I'll see you [__]
sweet where the skies are blue I'm a
little [__] up the lyrics yeah I'm
saying but I love you stay black keep
your eyes open Isis is still lurking
keep the eyes open you know I'm saying
you here's some [__] it's time don't
ever forget nothing don't forget nothing
I don't care how y'all keep your eyes
open and keep your hand ready a [__]
karate chop the [__] the neck
and if anybody asks you tell them uncle
Joey set you have a great weekend I love
your [__] be healthy hug your
family and [__] that's it stay back